[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con el amigo
meses representante estudiantil de la
universidad nacional sede medellín para
conversar que a propósito de las
protestas en colombia que no paran desde
el 28 de abril contra el gobierno de
iván duque a mi bienvenido a france 24 y
comienzo preguntándole cuál es el papel
del movimiento estudiantil en estas
protestas cuáles son sus demandas
bueno el movimiento si realmente es
bastante bastante amplio nos llevamos
parte de la cresta es uno de esos
sectores dentro del movimiento
estudiantil y pues hay bastantes
lecturas alrededor del tema sin embargo
hay una cosa que es bastante concreta y
es que desde las universidades desde el
movimiento estudiantil y profesoral nos
hemos estado movilizando en contra de
este modelo de educación que nos ha
llevado a una crisis estructural el
producto de la desfinanciación que
promueve la del 30 y como está afectado
a nuestras universidades y desde ahí se
llevan los problemas como bienestar
universitario todo lo que tiene que ver
con la matrícula y el acceso universal a
la universidad todo todo el tema
estructural ya desde forma digamos
[Música]
de infraestructura dentro de las
universidades elegirán ahí estamos
movilizándonos con respecto a eso y
concretamente pues en este en este en
este tiempo hemos estado movilizando por
por el tema de la matrícula cero y por
el tema del cumplimiento de los acuerdos
firmados con el gobierno nacional en el
año 2018 y también rechazando toda esta
violencia en las movilizaciones mire en
relación a la reunión del gobierno con
el comité nacional del paro qué es lo
que ustedes esperando este encuentro
nosotros creemos desde las 3 porque
repito ahí hay muchas muchas
interpretaciones creemos desde la crees
que hay que apostarle a esa mesa de
negociación de todas formas sabemos que
no es difícil y que es muy difícil
porque negociar con el gobierno nacional
sin embargo creemos que es la mejor
forma para acechar la violencia dentro
de nuestro país y durante una alocución
presidencial precisamente el mandatario
anduvo que habló de enfrentamientos
entre indígenas y ciudadanos usted qué
opina de esa diferenciación
a mí realmente me parece bastante
equivocado por parte del gobierno
nacional que se esté planteando una
diferencia extra tipo yo creo que es
bastante rechazable por parte de la
sociedad colombiana y este acto del
presidente que claramente es un acto de
discriminación hay que rechazar
y hasta cuando piensan mantener las
movilizaciones cuando es suficiente yo
creo que el gobierno nacional tiene que
atender las demandas del comité nacional
de paro el tema de los hay unos puntos
establecidos que son seis puntos del
pliego nacional de emergencia en donde
está la renta basel básica la
reactivación económica la matrícula cero
mayores recursos para las instituciones
públicas para atender los temas de
bioseguridad pero también la vacunación
y ahí también está todo lo que tiene que
ver con derechos humanos es retirar la
reforma a la salud que es un punto que
hemos estado exigiendo y esta nueva
reforma activos de área que nos vayan a
presentar no vaya a ser privatizando
ninguna ninguna de las empresas del
estado entonces pues ahí son seis puntos
grandes del pliego de emergencia
y eso es lo que vamos a negociar con el
gobierno finalmente que saben de los
desaparecidos en las protestas cómo se
están protegiendo entre los estudiantes
pues es realmente muy muy muy complicado
ai ai ai ai ai protocolos de seguridad
de algunos colectivos hay muchos
colectivos de derechos humanos que
atienden esto sin embargo es bastante
bastante bastante complicado porque la
fuerza pública de líder
y ha intervenido sin ningún tipo de
protocolo atacando directamente la
protesta social violando todo de todo
tipo de derechos humanos y eso es
bastante bastante complicado lo hacen en
las horas de la noche y esto pues
obviamente agrava agravar la situación
y pues eso lo vemos directamente en todo
lo que lo que ha estado ocurriendo a mí
pues muchas gracias a ustedes y sigan
con nosotros en france 24
[Música]